good morning John two days from now will
be the tenth anniversary of the first
vlogbrothers video being uploaded to
YouTube but there were people who watch
that video when they were 11 year olds
who can now get drunk and those 10 years
I have done a lot of things that dreams
are made of I made so many amazing
friends I toured in a rock band I played
Carnegie Hall I bought my first home I
grew up stayed young created VidCon and
scishow and crash course helped other
amazing talented creators turn their
visions into real things I became a
bobble head invented 2d glasses and I
interviewed the president of all the
things that we've done in the last 10
years the thing that I'm most proud of
is this community and I know that that
sounds hokey and made-up but let me
explain we are in a time of cultural
upheaval that's probably true of
everyone who's ever lived but it seems
particularly strong right now the
internet is gonna have a an unknowable
effect on human culture and I think that
effect is going to be huge and it's
gonna be both positive and negative the
thing that's been occupying my mind a
lot lately and this isn't just the
Internet this has been going on for a
long time is the disappearance of
traditional structures for community and
that so far not a lot has taken the
place of those structures except for
just diehard individuals and there are
good things that come from that
but I think it's also sort of resulted
in an explosion of distrust among people
and an explosion of cynicism especially
in young people I don't like the idea
that the only thing you could put your
faith in is yourself because one it's
not true and two where does it leave us
in those moments that we all have when
we don't actually like ourselves that
much and those moments might be getting
more common as we see all of these
people on the internet with their
perfect lives and their pretty faces and
their giant travel budgets and all their
followers don't want individualism to go
away nor do I think I could make that
happen it's so new and so different and
so pervasive that there aren't a lot of
structures to help it exist while also
not destroying society now that's a big
statement that's based on not a lot of
research but I don't think it's
controversial to say that we need new
community structures now a lot of people
would and have said that John and I we
are leaders of a community and of course
in many ways that is true i lastly
believe that more than being a leader of
this community I am a follower of it so
for 10 years we've tried to build a
place where people can be comfortable
and excited and enthusiastic in a
tumultuous and weird
in history but we have not done that by
seeing this target ten years off and
charging straight through the forest a
day I didn't know what we were doing we
didn't know how to do it I do what I am
being told to do when people leave
comments and they say this was my
favorite video ever and people say thank
you this really helped me or I feel like
a better person after watching this
video that's how we choose what we do I
am being led through this process I
don't know what I'm doing but somehow
over these ten years by wanting to do
this and by listening we've created a
community that provides joy and
connection and value and even meaning
for a lot of people definitely for me
that doesn't look like any of the
previous things that were community I
got to go back and say individualism is
great like we need it we need to believe
in ourselves we need to give that power
to individual people but we can't also
discard community striking that balance
is a huge challenge that we need to face
right now because there are big problems
that need to be faced not by these
leaderless collectives that we have seen
that where the individuals have tons of
energy but there's no cohesive community
to focus that energy we need to figure
out how to be both leaders and followers
how to be both ourselves and part of
something bigger than ourselves
we've spent 10 years trying to figure
out how to do that it's hard it's
complicated the model doesn't exist and
this is why I say that nerdfighteria is
the most interesting thing that I have
ever been a part of it is a model for
that we have had the time to try the
things out we figured out some things
that worked and some things that haven't
and other people elsewhere have also
figured those things out and they also
lead us people from Mark Twain to vihart
from Michelle Obama to Zay Frank from
Reinhold Niebuhr to Nathan's Ed like
wide varieties of amazing people I
really think that we need to find the
tools for how to do this and we need to
find them pretty quick look underneath
the 10 years the amazing things that
we've done like things that are in the
news and people talked about in like
people respect us for but underneath all
of it is this thing that's confusing and
hard to understand an amorphous that is
this community that no one understands
how big of a deal it is
how interesting it is and how maybe
important it is when I say that
nerdfighteria is the thing that I'm most
proud of of all the very cool things
that I've been able to do I'm not saying
that as some kind of like you know
slogan to try and like increase
enthusiasm for the community though
absolutely I want that not saying that
just as like a cheerleader for the
values of this community though I am
also one of those I'm saying it because
it's a model for how we build community
in a in a distributed internet-based
hyper individualized world which at the
moment we have very few of which is why
I am obsessed with this and I'm so proud
to be a part of it and I want to say to
everybody who has watched who has
participated over the last 10 years
thank you for being my leader also what
I'm saying is this video is longer than
four minutes isn't it and I couldn't do
anything about that not made a lot of
overtime videos I'm doing it right now
because I just I couldn't and also I had
at the end I wanted to say that this
community is getting together in the
real world for our first like this is a
central place that we're trying to get
as many nerdfighters in the same place
at the same time for in Boston in
February 25th and 26th at nerdcon
nerdfighteria and
I hope very much that is many people who
can come will come because I know that
being in the real world with people is
an important part of community and it's
an important part of me learning about
this community and being led by and also
since those two things they mesh
together so well this long video and
nerd Conner criteria I have a great
chance an opportunity if you will to get
punished in front of people and so I've
decided that I'm going to do that so
this video is too long punishment coming
we will record it and upload it but the
people at that nerd gun nerd Viteri will
get to see it live not sure what it's
going to be yet but I will be punished
it's been a while and I'm looking
forward to seeing some folks in February
John I'll see you on Tuesday